What's up, everyone!
uhhhh
What is this? PewDiePie playing video games? Oh, oh! I'm playing "Magic".
The official game of virgins
uuhhhh
We're about to hit platinum rank, I'm playing with my genius deck, 'angry white people'.
Which is a white-red aggro deck.
If you guys, haven't played Magic before I'm sure this will be very confusing.
But it's basically...
It's a video game. So that's all you need to know.
Okay, great. uhhhh
We've actually been playing Magic with a couple of people in Brighton like PJ, Joel...
uhhhh
Sometimes...
Dave comes down as well. Am I missing anyone? I don't know. We'll keep this, by the way.
It's been really fun. Really nostalgic.
I used to play Magic when I was a kid and I didn't under- Oh my god, you got destroyed! Ni- fuck, I didn't even...
We're getting closer to platinum!
See, this is how easy Magic is for me. People just see me and they run away in fear.
I don't even have to play the game to assert my dominance.
That's how good we are.
Next victim! What the hell just happened there? Did he just look at his hand?
and HAh HAh
Now, this is not a great hand, but i'll keep it just cuz i don't like getting crippled.
And that's not against cripples.
Maybe a little bit....
Alright, great we're playing against red.
Do I play Adanto and let it get killed... what do I do here?
Fuck, alright, next time we can play that so... we'll play this guy.
That's... That's the idea.
He's got three MANA!!!
Risk Factor!
Now
One, two, three, four, five...
Six, seven, eight. You'll have to just...
Why is he playing Risk Factor now?
Why?
"If you decline your..." I always mix these up.
I wouldn't have done it if you had one mana or less just so he doesn't do this spectacle.
But now he's gonna be like "Oh, huh-uh...
I got him."
No, you didn't I have... I have aggro stuff too, buddy.
Look at that, what are you gonna do about that?
Look, we're almost the same now. Almost. Fuck.
Don't worry, boys. We have Heroic Reinforcements.
What are you gonna play now? Again!
Okay, so one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, okay.
Why is he playing Risk Factor?
We'll take action, right? We'll take the damage cause I think... he's gonna get f******.
Does he have a spectacle?
I know I went against what I just said, don't spectacle me.
Please don't spectacle my Legion War Boss.
Oh, he didn't. Okay we're good.
You don't understand what you've just done.
One, two, three, four, five, six....
Seven, eight, nine...
So the question is do we wait for History Benalia... no, we don't.
I need to start doing damage.
I will attack with everything.
Alright. Mentor, who do we mentor?
Guess, one of my boys.
One of my green boys.
Do you feel the pain?!
Drop another Risk Factor, I dare you.
Okay, watch me get three Thunderbolts.
He dropped another Risk Factor!
Okay, if you decline...
Okay. Well, we won the game.
So now I decline so you can... draw your cards, alright?
You can have them. Congratulations.
What the hell is this? I've never seen this.
If he plays a fourth one.
Alright, you can only really do one more thing...
Incredible! Nice!
Nice! Good job! Thinking... what do I do?
Oops, oh, that's too bad. Well played, though.
F**** idiot!!!
So hot in here.
We're almost there. One more!
And we're platinum, baby.
We're no longer in
sub-zero IQ tier.
A lot of times when I play Magic... I seriously question myself.
If I'm actually retarded. [laughs]
Because you know this as soon as you make a mistake in this game and it just hurts so much.
We're playing against someone called Powerful.
It's actually not that great.
But we can remove some bitches and the green boy can be like "hey, what's up?".
And this guy.
I hate the art of this. It makes me uncomfortable.
What is that mustache?
I don't like it. It doesn't look even.
And like what is he getting hunted by? He doesn't even look hunted.
[burps] I like his shirt, though. But then again, his shirt has checkers here and stripes here.
All right. That's all I got about that.
That's my little...
Just click "Okay", goddamn it!!!
"Your opponent is choosing to keep their hand."
Don't think too hard!
People are so goddamn slow in this game sometimes.
please play Land! Just play Land and do your thing!"
Because they ain't playing if it takes him this long.
Well, what was my choice? It was stupid. [laughs]
Does he start as well?! That f**** bitch!!!
Let's see how powerful you are, mister. Oh god, it's Red again.
I really think I was just lucky last game that he didn't... Oh god, I just realized
I can't even play anything on first turn.
Okay, we'll play Red just so he feels intimidated.
By my little... my little dude over here.
That's right! I'm not at the Fareed deck. What you got about that?
Please tell me he didn't throw any Lands. That's my only way of winning.
They'll play the Land... Oh wait, it wasn't his turn yet. There we go.
Interesting.
Okay.
Well, things could definitely be worse. Do I want to get rid of that right away?
Yeah, I don't want to take a bunch of damage.
Hello.
I don't think we're gonna win this one.
I can feel that already like I lost too much tempo.
And I'm not a control deck so like what am I even doing at this point
If I play Legion's Landing now and Hunted Witness then next turn I can...
Get Legion's Landing switch, but it doesn't matter cause I'll have Heroic forces anyway.
But if I play this I'll just lose one of my goblins essentially and it won't really matter
So... I know this is a bit weird.
But at least I'll have some defense.
Why am I playing defensive aggro? I don't... don't ask, okay?
Now cast your Shock on my Hunted. Oh, you don't have one. That's too bad. Oh, you're not even gonna attack!
What?!
Okay.
All right. Well, I guess, we're both idiots.
Now... the move of the century!
Watch me whip! Green boy!
Is he gonna Shock... you don't Shock green boy! Ain't nobody shocking my boy.
Okay.
And then we transform Legion's Landing and next turn you will [smth swedish]. we say in Sweden.
You Shock-ed my green boy! Oh now I'm very angry ><
Plan completely ruined. That son of a gun. He has two mana though. He has two mana! Mana. I didn't even realize.
All right. Well, green boy is still very angry.
All right, well. you can't do anything so I might as well get rid of these.
You can't do anything! Just click!
Thank you.
Hello, we're back what's up!
Okay, now...
The play of the century coming right up!
Look at this. The fact that we haven't won against this f**** guy is just pathetic.
Cause honestly...
[laughs]
He doesn't have any Land.
He just took it what a champ! Legion is back, boy!
What are you sitting on? Another one! Attack with your Pyromancer, please.
What is this? What a weird game! You know that boy has a Shock.
Alright, well, now they're all pathetic and I don't like it but I'm gonna... just to show that I have the bigger penis.
We'll keep that one. It's so confusing!
All right, you will block with that and then you will let the rest go. Like a good boy.
Okay, and we get some health which is good. Health is good. We have no cards!
What are you doing?
This is...
Oh, Jesus!
He's got a ball of...
stuff. It's not a ball. It just hit me. I always thought it was like a sponge of jellyfish ball.
Well, I'm disappointed. Yes!
Okay, let's do some math. You can block three of my strongest which are all shit
so one, two, three, one, two, three four, he doesn't die this turn. Motherfucker!
I think we should...
Oh, god, I hope this is not the wrong move.
I just think he's gonna do one damage to me. It doesn't matter, alright? If I would be dead, I would be dead already.
Okay. All right, and then another one of these and then... we're all in, baby. Here we have one health less.
But he won't have any wizards which is nice.
And...
I don't think he can do anything. Okay?
What are you gonna do? That's right! Bye! Oops. Oops.
There it is. Ah!
Okay, look at that! One more game!
It's just this is the third time I won a game from diamond. And I saved the Lava Coil. That's the best part.
Yeah, I'll save it!
Shut the fuck up! How overpowered is that f**** card! It's insane!
Angry white people. I swear to god!
The only weakness... the one weakness angry white people have are angry angry people basically,
Mana Red. If I play against them a f**** Mana Red for the third fucking time, I'm going for Diamond
I'm gonna be so super duper pissed!
Okay, let's go. Let's freakin do this!
Okay. Hello.
Say it back.
Say it. Oh, oh, it's my turn. Okay.
We're gonna assert our dominance and play Legion's Landing.
I realize I should always play Legion's Landing first because I don't want to risk it getting convert.
Which could definitely happen.
It's like oh it's a gate deck.
That is very scary because I think definitely I can beat a gate deck.
I'm just gonna make sure I don't make any misplace so I can't play anything else this turn but this.
And I'll play this tapped and then go forth, my little vamp! There you go, we won!
I've lost it. I'm so f***** orange what is happening? I've lost against the...
With one f**** mana I swear to God. A health, I mean. Why do I have this in my deck now?
Why you ask?
Cause I'm so sick of f**** mana. I look like a f**** ...
Something. I look like something. My my shirt is definitely not yellow. Let's just put it the way.
Dude, we're gonna do two damage now, this changes everything!
Gate a blaze coming right up! Boom. Boom. Boom all gone. Okay play it. There it is.
Oh, I'm shocked. You should have waited till next turn though, you dingus,
Seriously, you can wait one f**** turn.
All attack, maybe he has another one.
That would f**** make me cry but it would be pretty funny if he doesn't have another one.
I would laugh ha! If you have us another one, I will scream!
Please. Hello. Please, like I'm hitting you up with Hello-s over here.
Please. Please, do you understand this? I just need to win this game. I'll let you win any other game afterwards.
If he hits me with a Gate Ablaze...
That's not what it's called, is it? It is! What an epic name!
And hits me with a Hello.
There's hope in the world. There's hope and peace. I think maybe he has won but he's worried about...
He could be worried about getting ligma... what am I saying?
I feel like I might as well play this cause there's really no other move I can make. "Creatures you control gain lifelink..."
I really really don't need this.
At all, I don't know what he's thinking about countering it.
What? What is that? "Copy target instant or sorcery spell with converted mana... You may choose new targets for the copy."
Does that mean we get it? Yeah.
All right, I'm confused.
We might as well give it to ourselves and he'll mentor.
Boom.
We hit him like a... f**** hurts!
Now we're gonna play Legion's Landing. Is there any point of playing Legion's Landing?
No, there isn't because we can easily play it next turn and if he hits me up with another Gate Ablaze...
I will cry! I never been this close! Good game. Oh!!!
Hello! Thank you!!!!!!!!!
Finally diamond!!!!!!
I've been trying all day like a f**** virgin loser! Diamond!! Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I don't care it's whatever. I really don't care.
Honestly, like diamond is pretty easy to get. It's whatever. Holy shit. I feel so fucking good!
F*** yeah! Now we're going for Mythic, baby! Easy. Angry white people.
No, one can smash him. No one can stop Angry white people.
This is my deck. I'm gonna link it if anyone wants to play with it. It's literally nothing special.
But it's Angry white people. Damn. That feels good. See, who said I wasn't a gamer! Why do I look so f**** crazy?
I play real man's games.
Alright, leave a like if you want more of this. Maybe this is completely incoherent and people don't know anything about Magic.
I don't know but I had fun! So there's that... Bye!